Denise we all know the housing market is
Shifting but we still see homes like
this being built all across the valley I
spoke with an expert about you know what
yet another interest rate hike means for
brand new bills
why not go new instructions Bernard
barbilla is in the market for a new home
not only are you trying to find the
perfect home but at the same time you're
trying to find it timely he and his wife
are looking to build from the ground up
but he says they've had to switch their
strategies as the market changes
on Wednesday the Federal Reserve
announced yet another interest rate hike
bringing a fixed 30-year mortgage to
about 7.3 percent
so what does this mean for new
developments as far as the new home
construction uh selling I I it's still
there's still a lot of activity Brian
almero of Highlands Residential Mortgage
says while things have slowed slightly
buyers from California are still adding
to our local expansion with more than
223 new projects in the works there are
home prices there a lot more than than
what we have here so for them they still
think it's a bargain still higher
payments are a struggle for many buying
locally with some backing out of
contracts so almero recommends locking
an interest rate as fast as you can I
think one of the biggest things is just
I guess dumb luck perfect timing
whatever you want to call it if like
Bernard you're looking for a brand new
start hopefully when all said and done
we'll we'll be we'll be in the right
place where we need to be
now Brian says because the market has
changed so much in the last few months
home builders are offering a lot of
incentives to offset closing costs and
other expenses to make homes here in the
valley more affordable reporting live
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now